[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
pour
vit et puis où il y a cette
correspondance incroyable entre une
nature que j'aime très hostile et puis
des un mode de vie nomade qui
me j'avais surtout envie de revenir dans
les endroits qui ont beaucoup compé pour
moi il y a il y a déjà 20 ans c'estàd la
comment app ça la Haute Asie dans tous
ces confins on a parfois un peu
l'impression que c'est le laboratoire
des âes esselé qui se sont reclu pour
des raisons voulues ou subies mais qui à
chaque fois ont une vision du monde qui
est assez
[Musique]
particulière au prémises du printemps
Sylvain Tesson et quelques amis font
route vers les confins de la Sibérie
mongole ils veulent traverser le lac
rousgou et tenter d'atteindre tout au
nord les tsatan le peuple des éleveurs
de
rennes 2 ans après l'accident qui a
failli lui coûter la vie Sylvain Tesson
est de retour sur les route de
l'aventure c'est la première fois depuis
sa sortie d'hôpital qu'il remonte sur
une
moto le froid ça durcit les durites tu
vois c'est c'est
chiant sont tous de la même taille après
c'est comme tout c'est tous de la même
taille mais il faut les
[Musique]
essayer c'est pas le cas qui va protéger
bah si ça te protège quand même si tu
tombes ouais mais sur le lac tu peux pas
tomber ah
bon tu montreras moi je suis pas un
spécialiste de la cascade mais on en a
d'autes du coup j'ai un casque intégral
je Seris un peu moche par rapport à vous
quoi je sais pas pourquoi les pouvoirs
publics nous oblige de mettre un casque
sur les motos ce qui en fait est très
une très mauvaise idée ça attire le
mauvais œil mais va expliquer ça un
flic monsieur l'agent je mets pas ça
attire le mauvais œil il comprend pas on
pourra essayer s
croise ah oui tuas des
manchons
comme je vois plus rien je conduit à
l'oreille ouais alors comme j'ai qu'une
oreille conduit avec la tête à gauche et
le reste à l'intuition et à l'espoir
aussi l'espoir étant une insulte au
moment
présent on a à peu près une centaine de
kilomètres pour aller jusqu'à rgal plein
nord sur le lac
c'est de la piste goudronné par moment
ou bien goudronné et gelé qu'elle sera
pas forcément déblayée donc bon voilà
gardez la distance entre vous pour les
freinages et tout ça qu'on aille pas se
percuter entre nous ça serait
[Musique]
bal le principe de la moto c'est que tu
lis la poésie avant de partir et ensuite
au fur à mesure que tu avances lentement
dans la STEP en avant calme et droit tu
réfléchis tu médite pendant que le
moteur lui fait la même chose un moteur
c'est une petite réduction parfaite d'
d'un monde en ordre de marche au début
je démarre juste et puis après tu la
redémar je te regarde bien alors pas
[Musique]
louper
avec les pistons les bi l'huile tout est
là tout est parfaitement à sa place et
tout permet
d'avancer c'est très beau symboliement
mot de moto et la méditation c'est
pareil met du carburant et après je vais
réfléchir l'intervention de Posidon
pendant la g de 3 voil ça va m'emporter
magnifiquement pendant que le moteur
luiême est en train de de meer
[Musique]
au rendez-vous de ce voyage il y a Jean
Burd qui s'est attelé à une tâche
inédite celle de marier une moto
indienne un panier de SIDEC russe Alex
zcher et Baptiste chaper ont soufflé
l'idée de la route thasas le photographe
et compagnon de toujours des nuits de
grand vent a suivi encore une
cinquantaine de kilomètres et ils seront
au portes de leur rêve celui d'une Gliss
sur les reflets d'un lac
[Musique]
gelé de temps en temps là quand on
marche des craquements
sinistres qui sont pas le bruit le plus
agréable dans une vie humaine
ouis direct là ça
passe
[Musique]
c'est sûrement une rivière ou un truc
comme ça tu vois et comme il fait bon
bah ça
dégèle voilà c'est un grand classique
dans ces cas-là on a le choix entre deux
solutions soit
la
finesse soit à la russe je pense que
Sylvain là il va pas tenter la finesse
il va bouriner un peu et il va avoir du
mal à passer mais on va rigoler au
moins
[Musique]
ça me plaît beaucoup ce paysage là par
ça me fait penser à la peinture je sais
pas pourquoi enfin si je sais pourquoi
d'ailleurs mais à la peinture
hollandaise
[Musique]
quoi
l'hiver à la fois doux et et
effroyable c'est le néant et la douceur
là tout paraî mort et tout paraît
doux
j'aime beaucoup moi les paysages o qui
ressemblent à des tableaux
réciproquement
des c'est exactement de ces
panoramason a besoin après une journée
de
petad sur des moteurs de 500 cm
C je serai un peintre je planterai
éternellement mon chevalet devant ce
simple paysage là c'est résurgence d'eau
qui ressemble à un liquen
épidermique pâle et livide et puis le
contour de la forêt qui vient subitement
s'arrêter là où commence la rivière et
qui dessine un cerne noir enfin voilà
mais tout ça ce sont des descriptions
c'est des c'est des vieux réflexe de de
de vieux jeux plus personne ne décrit
rien aujourd'hui on ne décrit plus
aujourd'hui çamerde tout le monde tout
le monde a d déjà s'endormir au moins je
peux servir de
sorfique ce qui m'aura donné finalement
une forme
[Musique]
d'usage
ouais ah oui là oui avec l'oiseau au
dessus ouais
ah oui ça c'est vraiment la volute des
corps que tu vois sur les
pierres je pense que il y a quelque
chose de sacré pour les
Mongols dans la
glace c'est d'ailleurs quelque chose qui
est très
bouddhiste puisque c'est de l'éphémère
qui a une forme
solide ils font des statues avec des
figures totemiques anim
myique comme le soleil avec quelque
chose qui est provisoire pu que ça
fond et donc c'est une très belle
idée la porte de glace d'un royaume
qui qui ne durera pas mais qui est là à
l'instant on le
voit j' bien cette
idé c'est quelque chose de fascinant l'
ou toutes les activités de l'homme qui
consistent en imp age dans un endroit où
il n'a pas à être et où il ne peut pas
rester longtemps moi me fcine
l'alpinisme c'est pareil on trace une
voie dans un endroit où on n pas
vraiment à être et on peut pas rester
longtemps et à peine arrivver au sommet
il faut redescendre ben une traverser
d'un lac gelé c'est pareil c'est un
élément où on n pas vraiment à être qui
ne durera pas il faut simplement tracer
une ligne et c'est ce qu'on va faire
avec nos motos c'està-dire on va faire
un itinéraire qui sera une trace un
sillage mais qui ne laissera pas trace
toute trace qui ne laisse pas de
trace me m'attire beaucoup
[Musique]
moi
ils ont enlevé la
neigeus la
neige comme ça on va chaud
voil vrai
encl tu VO
[Musique]
truc
z non franchement là
regarde
il est mort de rè il préfère il est
comme ça ah ils ont le bétit dans le
sang
[Rires]
quoi il regardz il était comme
ça il n faut pas que du petit bois non
plus je sais pas B do à chaque fois il
revient il me dit de recouper plus
petit doigt ou ouais c'est
[Musique]
ça
une nuit dehors c'est jamais une nuit
perdue jamais c'est au contraire
une une sorte de
présent qu'on s'accorde à
soi-même le feu les arbres le
vent c'est merveilleux de M de temps en
temps évidemment quand on y est quand on
y est pas
contraint j'avais très très mal au dos
j'avais mal partout j'étais
fracassé et le le simple fait de me
plonger dans la nature pendant quelques
semaines
ça a valu toute rééducation hospitalière
c'est
sûr mais parce que psychiquement là on
voit des spectacles qui
sont le feu la glace le ciel le soleil
qui tombe le lac qui vit en
craquant on est dans
l'élément il y a aucun interface on est
dans des toutes petites choses en des
gestes
éternels
ceux qui ne comprennent vraiment c'est
les
enfants proposer à un enfant d'aller
dormir dehors autour d'un feu dans les
bois avec comme seule musique le bruit
du vent dans les arbres c'est c'est un
rêve absolu pour l'enfant alors après il
y a une coupure qui s'appelle l'âge
adulte tout d'un coup on décide de
devenir un civilisé et se couper
totalement de cette amitié profonde avec
la nature et puis il y en a certains
d'entre nous qui reste un peu ancré dans
cette
dans dans dans cette poésie de l'enfance
alors je crois que tout le monde ici sur
cette île est comme
ça c'est dommage je pense de de de de
couper le le lien c'est comme
si on coupait pour une deuxième fois le
cordon une première fois quand on n et
puis une deuxième fois quand on décide
que la nature n'est plus du
tout un élément dont on
procède mais ça je pense que c'est une
mauvaise obstétrque
[Musique]
celle-là
non
[Musique]
mais
par contre tu vois la
différence
[Applaudissements]
faut pas penser à grand-chose en fait
parce que il faut plutôt regarder ce
spectacle assez
onirrique le visage du lac c'est une
mosaïque en fait il y a encore des
pastilles de neige qui ressemblent à de
l'anacre après on arrive sur quelque
chose un espace qui est très sombre très
noir comme de l'obsidienne ou comme la
peau des cachalot après on arrive sur
des grandes surfaces bleuté qui sont
traversé par des fractures blanches un
peu meringué enfin on pourrait comme ça
un peintre deviendrait fou
[Musique]
ici
ça ressemble à un rêve en
fait il faut Imagineer être sur une
mongolfière et puis traverser un pays un
[Musique]
monde
c'est pour ça qu'en fait on devrait
jamais s'arrêter de rouler sur les lacs
gelés ça devrait être le seul objectif
d'une
[Musique]
vie
u
pas
non c'est quoi cette moto dis que je
veux
l'acheter tu crois que quand ils auront
fini ils vont te la
vendre pourquoi
pasce qu'il fait
a
et ces derniers jours tu entendu la
glace craqué ça m'inquiète un peu
oui c'est inquiétant c'est
craquement il y a un dépage habitu qui
est devenu trop
dangereux température se réchauffe et ça
devient
risqué la route par laquelle vous êtes
entré est déjà
fissuré il y a une large faille
désormais il va falloir qu'on tourner à
votre
tour le chauffeur j'ai l'impression que
il nous a dit de d'accélérer conneries
là parce qu'il y avait les deux gros
camions qui arriv et je pense qu'il
avait peur que ça
[Musique]
fragilise là tu vois les camions
arrivent et je me demande il va pas
faire activer la machine en même temps
c'est vrai que c'est pas rassurant C
espèce de cTAR de 15 tonnes
[Musique]
là
une espèce d' là du coup
c'est différence de de mouvement entre
la glace de lance qui est enfermé dans
les terres et tout le reste du lac du
coup ça fait comme des plaques
tectoniques qui se
pouss
regarde si sol il faut voir surtout en
dessous est la profondeur quo et pu si
tuas juste petre S et derrière la
glace
ce choc là sera celui de trop pour le
panier du
SIDEC tout au nord du lac il faut dévier
la route et s'arrêter pour réparer ce
qui peut encore
[Applaudissements]
l'être
ah il y a un gars qui a un poste à
souder un poste à souder
oui il va pouvoir siil gars veut il va
il va pouvoir si a un bout de ferraille
lui souder une pâte
poura cons fond de la caisse ouais c'est
pas con ça sinon on met une planche
ouais ouais en même temps vu que c'est
des vieilles caisses qu'on a récupéré
sur des motos locales c'est aussi
logique que ah il y a pas le chix peti
fragilité
quoi B voilà c'est ça ça il faut qu'il
la soude en dessous en
dessous non non une
seous VO que là aussi c'est Abé
pour mais on va la démonter la
caiss tu veux CIG pour de
tonus
l'ID il ve pas souder il veulent pas
souder ouais ils veulent pas souder
c'est
trop non mais l'idéal ça serait d'avoir
une plaque qui revienne sur le
[Musique]
côté
parfait la moto tout mon pane on ém un
diagnostique
on on résout le problème et la moto
repart c'est magnifique ça s'appelle une
action accomplie une action juste une
action
vertueuse là la mécanique peut
l'offrir merci non je me suis toujours
demandé pourquoi on
avait cette ce plaisir incommensurable à
voyager sur des motos et je me suis dit
un jour en lisant un récit de Joseph
Kessel qui s'appelle les dames de
Californie où Kessel explique qu'il a
jamais su trancher entre deux penchant
contraire qui était en lui un penchant
pour le voyage et un penchant pour le
repos il appelle ça la difficile
équation entre l'arrêt et le mouvement
et il me semble que quand on est sur une
moto on résout cette équation là cette
espèce de tiraillement intérieur qui
fait que d'un côté on a envie d'être un
nomade de s'agiter de voir du pays et
puis de l'autre on a envie de temps en
temps de moments de repli intérieur de
repos de concentration de retour en soi
la moto l'offre cette équation on est
assis on a la PL des gaz enfoncé la
route défil on avance le monde passe les
kilomètres s'ajoutent au kilomètres on
voit le paysage comme ça sur les bords
qui se déroule et soi-même pourtant on
est immobile et on peut méditer
[Musique]
il y a un moment où c'est le combat des
sens de la perception qui déte les
réflexes et qui te disent il faut
freiner parce que je vois arriver
quelque chose qui ressemble à de l'eau
non justement faut pas freiner il faut
que l'esprit que la raison que
l'intellect explique au sens à
l'appareil sensitif et sensoriel qui va
déclencher les réflexes que ce n'est pas
de l'eau et qu'on peut y aller avec la
[Musique]
moto
bonjour moi c'est
Gamba je suis avec mes bê du matin
jusqu'au
soir c'est mon quotidien
DEP ça fait 35 ans maintenant que je vis
ici quand on s'est marié avec ma femme
on a reçu une centaine d'animaux en
cadeau et aujourd'hui on en a plus de
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
500 le destin des peuples est très
étrange parce que tu peux passer de la
crainte du fléo de Dieu comme s'appelait
Attila à une nation tout à fait stable
et qui essaie de gagner sa prospérité
calmement les Mongoles c'était la
terreur de l'Occident av jeiscan qui a
conquis tout l'Occident de son empire
c'était des gens qui étaient craints
dans les chroniques du moyen-âge on on
trouve des mentions de femmes qui
faisaient des fausses couches dans les
villes d'Europe quand elle sentaiit
l'odeur de l'armée mongole qui
[Applaudissements]
arrivé aujourd'hui la Mongolie c'est une
petite nation charmante stable en paix
qui essae de de se bâtir un destin qui
franchement est pas mal avec beaucoup de
succès tu rencontes que des des éleveurs
qui bâtifolent dans les steps dans les
prés comme quoi tout de même l'homme
n'est pas forcément premier au pire
parfois il s'améliore
[Musique]
une soupe rou avec du
RER il y a 3 mois
avecén
dans mais la dernière fois qu'on a
partagé un déjeuner comme ça d'ailles je
lu posé une question il m'a dit n ne
parlons pas nous
déjeons ah générouche le il y avait une
table couverte duré 10 minutes personne
n' dit un mot tout le monde bouffé il
rest de quoi nourrir TR régiments sur la
table culture
ça
[Musique]
la grande différence d'avec mes
premières années de voyage c'est que je
n'associis pas tout à
l'écriture tandis que maintenant c'est
ça qui me plaît beaucoup moi c'est
d'essayer de formuler ce que je
[Musique]
vois de formuler ce que je ressens de
formuler ce à quoi je pense et de
formuler ce que j'observe bien entend
de formuler également les idées les
modes de vie les comportements les
bizarreries beautés
[Musique]
aussi occupation très stimulante avec 26
lettres d'un alphabet d'essayer de
dépindre cette chose là
[Musique]
voilàon il est bien il son
bien
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on va aller en deux étapes vers chez
lessatan donc lessatan c'est ces
éleveurs de reennes là qui habitent à la
à la frontière russe environ 100 120 km
d'ici vers le vers l'ouest alors autant
sur la glace et sur la neige c'est assez
facile et puis ça pardonne les des
erreurs autant quand tu arrivve sur la
piste ça peut être plus compliqué parce
que les pistes sont souvent très
creusées par le passage des camions et
du coup bah la trème roue peut nous
amener à faire ce qu'on appelle des tout
droit pour ça j'ai mis un casque
aujourd'hui parce que il paraît moi je
connais pas très bien la moto ni les
règle de sécurité donc on m'a dit que le
casque est préférable à la ch c'està
dire que ça va nous changer de la patine
noire on va passer
du du patinage artistique au slalom
[Musique]
géant
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
quand il passe ici en gros c'est un peu
l'épreuve tu dois prendre la pierre la
soulever c'est
un
pas
jus
[Musique]
V
ça sert à rien de se mettre au milieu
pass TR B comme ça et faire les
allretours parce queç les motont
[Musique]
pas et si on si on insiste trop de ce
côté là il sera trop tard pour faire
demi-tour on
pas nous on ramène les
motos prier les villages on dort là-bas
ce soir et on vous attend demain matin
vous revenez assez tôt pour qu'on ait le
temps de faire le retour jusqu'à chez
Biamba non la chose qui est sûre c'est
que là on s'est arrêté à un endroit où
la route de la neige ça continue là
Sylvin to va Clément vous filez au au
tsatan voilà vous allez rencontrer les
les éleveurs de rennes euh vous partez
avec un was donc normalement tout
pourrait bien se passer et puis nous on
ramène les quatre motos avec
Jean-Baptiste Ghana
ce qu'il faut faire je te dis à cette
heure là de l'après-midi les heures
passent vite on a déjà mis 1 heure 1 he
de à faire 100 m avec les motos même si
ça passe sur 10 born déjà ça passe pas
même si on tire on tire et puis qu' a 10
bn Qui pass 10 born d'près passe pas on
se retrouve PL au milieu de la STEP
alors que la nuit se couche puis en plus
on risque de vraiment Abî les châssis
mer
l'aéropostal il fallait passer
il réessayait il prenait des courants
contrair il réessayait il a essayé 34
fois de décoller de son étend avec son
hydravion trop lourd il arriv au bout de
l' temps à la limite coup les moteurs il
revenait en arrière les mécaniciens non
non ça passera pas en arrête il repait
toute une journée
iless pas d'histoire de machine il y
avait pas d'histoire de on abandonne pas
dans le c'était pas dans leur
je et nous un m de neige sur 100
m c'est pas une histoire de mécanique ça
c'est une histoire de climat un moment
où ris de casser pour casser faire
n'importeoire n pas
c ça doit faire plus d'un mois que
personne n'est passé par ici regarde la
neige il n a presque plus de route
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonjour bonjour bonjour comment
allez-vous
entrez c'est par
ici
merci
c'est
quoi je fait
çaas uneère ton pou à la bas de ton
[Musique]
pouce fort
[Rires]
fort
il ve savoir si tu es le
chef oui je suis le plus vieux de cette
tribu il est Russie mais il a un
passeport
mongol quand nous étions jeunes nous
n'avions ni passeport mongol passort
russe ce n'est qu'à partir des années 60
qu'ils ont décidé de nous donner une
nationalité comme on était du côté
mongol nous sommes devenus
mongol les plus vieux d'entre nous n'ont
jamais réussi à faire les démarches et
beaucoup sont mors sans jamais avoir
appartenu à un
pays c'est un peuple 2 millions d'un
côté 400 ici pas 400 400 côté mongol de
milons côtés russes une frontière au
milieu des empires des nations et des
peuples qui se retrouvent à
cheval
merci c'est le les histoire des peuples
qui dont la patrie est une langue un
mode de vie un écosystème
alors eux c'est c'est l'écosystème de la
forêt et les montagnes c'est leorine
c'est cette langue et puis tout d'un
coup il y a les frontières politiques
quoi qui leur correspondent pas c'est la
vieille histoire c'est enfin c'est
tellement c'est tellement ordinaire sauf
que là on en a on a tout d'un coup un
témoignage
vivant ça ent taillé une chaîne de
montagne et de part et d'autres tu as le
même peuple la même langue le même
psychisme le même
comportement le même pacte avec la même
[Musique]
bête
ah il y a des loups qui
rodent nous allons rassembler les reenes
[Musique]
plusieurs personnes sont parties à leur
recherche car on va bientôt déplacer le
camp et le
troupeau
VO allô allô tu m'entends je t'entends
pas marche
pas vous savez quand vous
partez on ne sais pas
encore non seulement deux personnes sont
parties en
[Musique]
avanceexistence de de mondes un
archaïsme
etisme l'arme le téléphone un truc qui
marche pas qui est lait qui ENL le monde
qui abruti la relation humaine
AB la pensée qui s contre le souvenir
qui massacre l'inspiration qui détruit
le mystère ça c'est
ça une chose éternelle magnifique
technique
parait
[Musique]
34 du
café
44 et
voilà
[Musique]
oui c'est aujourd'hui le
déplacement on va charger celui-ci pour
la première
fois on va découper sa fourrure pour
éviter qu'il ne se blesse avec les
armatures on peut sentir que sa fourrure
est encore jeune et
souple on va voir comment il va
réagir il est fort mais il est
[Musique]
fou m'intéresse beaucoup au
fond chez les hommes que je rencontre
c'est de voir ce qui se maintient chez
eux de leurs très très vieilles origines
c'est ça qui m'intéresse chez
l' j'aime voir l'homme comme une sorte
de réceptacle du de la très profonde
histoire de la longue durée pour ça que
quand je vais chez les Mongols ça
m'intéresse de voir comment ils
s'asseillent dans leur maison comment il
se déplace comment il se salu comment il
se parle comment il rentrent les G et
les autres comment il ils vivent quand
ils sont en mouvement que ce soit dans
une camionnette sur une moto ou sur un
cheval j'aime bien voir des choses qui
me rappelle des très vieilles lectures
littéraires poétiqu ou historique et qui
racontaent exactement la même chose au
12e siècle à l'époque de jeaniscan il y
a comme ça des petits invariants des
choses qui ne changent
pas peu importe que qu'il y a des
camions des antennes paraboliques de
l'électricité et tout ça ce sont des
permanences qui ont traversé les siècles
et ça ça m' intéresse alors évidemment
quand on les décrit et quand on s'en
félicite et quand on les célèbre on a
l'impression que on est là en train de
faire une sorte d'idéalisation un peu
ridicule et muséographique mais non
simplement que on est très sensible
comme un syismographhe à la permanence à
la survie à la continuité moi ça
m'intéresse le continuum je suis plus
intéressé par ce qui
demeure par ce qui se maintient que
parce qu'il change et parce qu'il se
bouleverse